hello Gary welcome hi hi what what's up
today yes yes I wanted to ask you the
same thing how are you Gary what is up
with you what have you been doing I'm
fine I'm just you know I'm I'm counting
Counting decis of games in the
tournament you need one
hand try trying to reach high five
yes nice uh but Gary it's not through
lack of effort it's
the players are very important point you
know this is the this is what people
very often don't understand that it's
you know it's a it just shows that
opponents are just you know are um you
know deserve each other so that's the
you look at the at the computer score so
it's very often 98 99 so that's it's the
the Precision which means you know
that's they play good chess they do a
lot a lot of actually a lot of it's it's
it's it's bad it's bad luck for for for
for um for the viewers for for the for
the audience because it ends up with
with with drawers and and and no blood
is spilled but again you can't you can't
blame them for not trying yeah
absolutely and I've heard of the some
people on Twitter saying that it's it's
to do with a risk aversion that the top
players these days are just not inclined
to take risks um do you agree with that
opinion no now can you be more specific
because again Twitter audience you know
often you know just you
know it's comprised of Chess fans and
they just looking for you know all
romantic chess you know this fight blood
all over the board no but could beit
more specific what kind of risk so yes
you can probably blame them for not you
know playing um very sharp openings uh
okay uh the only decisive game so far
you know report play Kings India that's
why in in in in a computer era that's
already decisive
mistake so um but otherwise again they
they try they're trying they're trying
um yeah I again how you can force
players to do moves that are not
recommended by the computer because they
all prepare it with machines and um it's
you should blame probably the
development of machines as much as the
players un willingness to go against
machines advice right well today for
example to the point that you were
making uh Gary uh the game between mvl
and nepo nepo came and he played a very
challenging uh risky defense with Bishop
C5 Bishop A7 and tried to engage some
sharp lines with his opponent and the
mvl just shut it down on move
nine takes E5 yeah yeah yes sir yes sir
yes sir again I I'm I'm I'm out of
professional chess but I think I could
recognize that eventually with reverse
moves order they reached a famous
theoretical position what was Black
Bishop on A7 yes that was very
interesting idea because I think it just
you know it neutralizes A4 why's main
idea it's the same position but he he he
he he changed the move order and and he
had a bishop on A7 instead of B6 right
that's yeah and and I mvl couldn't find
any um
any anything wrong with the this new um
structure and he just took only5 which
is totally you know it's uh it's it's
very innocuous so you don't do it with
Bishop on B6 right exactly so that's
that should we give credit and Napo you
know came up with relatively simple idea
it's not that it's invented you know in
your bicycle but still playing Bishop C5
and then Bishop I and then B5 right
that's an interesting move s exactly and
it's confused them mvl Gary this is the
uh s cup obviously it's the end of the
2023 tour we'll be crowning a champion
it seems like one Fabiana Karana has
taken all of the mystery out of who's
going to be the grand chest Tor Champion
your perspective as the organizer it's
your brainchild how do you see this year
where are you satisfied with the grand
chest tour and uh what it has evolved
into look I'm very happy with with the
fact that we already here for so many
years yeah so when it started in 2015 it
was yes you know it's uh it's another
try and as we know many tries in the
world of chair they just you know they
show up a lot of Promise uh and then
just you know lost lost all um all the
excitement you know all the Steam and
run out right uh um uh and uh um as of
today you know I think the that's um we
we could see that this is the most most
prestigious classical event in the world
so now we even chess.com is covering
it yeah so and and um again it's it's
very important element now of the modern
Chess World because it's so easy to lose
the connection between professional
chess um um professional chess players
and classical chess and I think uh
singfield Cup and the whole Grand Tour
keeps it keeps this connection where we
have classical rapid bleeds and um and
we have huge interest so everybody wants
to play and um um okay Magnus doesn't
play the whole cycle but he plays rapid
you know and and and and Blitz so it's a
it's a major event and it has it has
very two very strong sponsors on both
sides of Atlantic and and we will
continue and again I think it's very
promising even fed now recognize the
importance because it being included in
in in in their very very comple complex
system of qualific I still couldn't
figure it out but I
know but I know somehow this results are
being being being counted but as you
said you know it's um it's unfortunate
for for chess fans but it's um it's very
natural development of this year events
because Fabiano was the he was the most
stable has most stable performance yeah
just every year very very solid you just
it's very impressive because now it's so
easy to play one tournament well and
then just you know you you
you lose your interest or concentration
and again he's no longer that young so
we know by by by even by stand of this
tournament so uh but his performance is
is quite impressive and that's why I
mean unless something very dramatic and
negative to him happens in the next few
days so we know the outcome exactly and
uh well looking to the future I mean
what do you hope to see for the next
Grand chest tour in
2024 look I don't think we have to
invent you know just something something
brand new it's the model if if you know
if it's if if if the tap is ain't
leaking you know you should you
shouldn't fix it is this I think it's
it's it's it's a working model and um I
think that we will um um just you know
keep keep up with with what we already
you know developed uh um ideally we
would like probably to add one more
event so one more rapid rapid event but
it to to increase number of players who
who can participate the problem is that
the Fe the calendar is so messy and
there so many events so that's why you
know you don't want to over um over to
make players overw work exactly so uh
but I would say that one more event
rapid you know it's event in somewhere
in Europe in Western Europe probably
would be a good idea because you see now
we have yeah we have kind of Gap because
we have uh Eastern Europe and and the
United States so it's amazing that you
know nothing happens you know between
between warso and London right uh I
remember we had a wonderful event in
Africa I think it was a rapid and Blitz
event there Gary that that extra event
that was a long long time ago yeah but
it was really really nice it was really
nice if you could revive that Gary uh
yeah look African continent is a little
bit now just you know it's um it's it's
it's it's a risky place for organ iers
because and sponsors because it's let's
say politically unstable um I think it's
will be difficult just have to be honest
but again my first interest would be to
do something in in Western Europe still
you know we have you know this this huge
um portion of the wall of chess with so
many registered players probably one
probably the highest number of
registered players per probably but per
per per per capita so it's not having
any any grunes to revents we had we had
was a period we had events in in Paris
yes now it's it's no longer there London
Paris and now it's it's it's a big empty
spot on on on our map exactly Peter join
in the conversation I know that you and
Gary enjoy your Fisher random chess uh
games together well Gary Den to enjoy
them more than I do I don't think I've
ever I've ever achieved 50% in our
training
so yeah
what's happening today yes exactly well
we unfortunately mvl and nepo they have
a very balanced position this balanc
ending rook and Bishop I think this one
is could even end as we speak yeah yeah
in a in a repetition so nothing's
happening there we think Leon oh pardon
me let's just uh go to the game of
Richie versus
Anish again pretty pretty balanced I
wanted to ask Gary because I think uh
his opinion will be the definitive one
on on this as many other positions just
how much better does Gary think leevon
is yes this is uh that was also that
that that that wasn't uh the position it
was this one uh Gary uh Bishop the board
dark dark Square Bishop for leavon
against Ali raza's Knight on C5 the
problem is you know the problem is since
I'm watching it online so I'm I'm few
moves I'm I'm behind there's a delay for
you unless you're willing to to to
reveal the mystery I think it's a
problem because sorry Gary we don't
we're talking fair play I'm on move 12
I'm onve 12 you're someway behind then
and I'm behind I I I suspect I know
what's happened probably you know was
this is he took on three eventually and
it's but again I I I can hardly you know
give my um my uh my opinion because it's
um you definitely have position probably
at move 16 or 17 now okay so indeed
you're were right Bishop B2 for white on
move 12
D5 C takes D5 Bishop takes C3 C3 Bishop
takes C3 no D6 D6 D6 ah D6 yes inzo
Queen takes D6 Queen takes C3 Queen
E7 D takes C5 Knight takes C5 so it's
two Bishop Bishops but the bishop on B2
is is it's very nice diagonal we like
white and and since you've played so
many matches with karpov you would have
a a very good feel for the advantage for
white how big is it this advantage in
your in
your mind yeah but black black is very
solid and uh
um um I'm thinking specific specifically
of game
24 in Spain the one you had to win yes
but it's yes but it's it was more about
psychology than about the call of the
position so this is not yeah keeping the
pieces alive keep the position alive I'm
um thinking
now um maybe white should play something
Queen E5 me too so shockingly Leon's
Choice was Knight F3 to E e 5 uh but I
agree Queen E5 just keeping Queen E5 was
interesting because it keeps you know
just black Under Pressure and
potentially you have something like
Knight H4 and Knight F5 as I don't know
if it works or not right because for
after Queen E5 was my move I saw playing
Knight H4 Bishop G2 Knight F5 probably
winning and Knight takes G7 or Knight H6
no Knight H6 Queen no Knight H6 Queen
takes F6
nice yeah Queen E5 let me just sh show
uh to our audience how we could how we
could lose this in Abracadabra in just a
few moves with the black side uh Bishop
knight5 Knight F5 Queen D7 defending the
bishop Knight nice H6 check oh very nice
you know this one Joy you studied this
as a young
lady and there you go so yeah Queen E5 a
little bit surprised ing for us was the
choice of leavon which was Knight
E5 it's probably still better for white
because you know this the then
eventually Pawn comes on F3 and black is
under pressure but it's a it's
unpleasant but I think que5 could be
even more more ambitious exactly exactly
more ambitious Gary uh I we we we talked
a little bit about the grand chest tour
the history the future but more
specifically
your history I saw you did a video
series uh chess 24 with Gary uh on the
YouTube it it looks like a a really
marvelous interview that you had with
levitov what uh projects chess projects
are you working on look it's it's you
know we finished the recording now so
that's is I don't it's I think is the
the 17 18 18us been released um and it
was very it was memorable because I had
to go throughout my early years and uh
and that's that all his suggestion so we
started it just the idea came up early
but eventually it's it's it's you know
it's happened after my mother passed
away so that's it's for her memory so
that's because there so many yeah events
there are connected directly or
indirectly to to to to the role she
played in my life um and that's you know
that's that took almost 2 years of
recording um uh because he kept cutting
it so that otherwise it would be
probably not 24 but just 100 hours and
the hero the uh um and it's they they
kept you know growing and every time you
know I recorded something I thought I
forgot this I forgot that so this is
It's if I if I had to do it again now so
it would be probably get quite different
because it's the um it's there so many
events that um that I I I I wanted to
include but then just you think about it
after after Mass that you already
recorded as ah I just forgot this one
for me it's such a wonderful personal
Memoir and it's just sort of like I
would have loved every world champion
from Alexander alakin to Emanuel Lasker
to Bobby fiser to have such uh a
personal uh trip down your memory l Lane
as your career cuz personally uh
congratulations I I I found it to be
outstanding and uh um no as you can
guess now I I'm doing much less CH than
other things you know these days so I um
yeah I wish I had more time uh but I
it's it's we have different war games
now in the
world yes Gary thank you so much for uh
joining us so I'll be back uh
at the the last round and of course I
will be at the opening ceremon at the
closing ceremony oh very
good forward to seeing you then and
thank you very much Gary for joining us
thank you for those of you again who uh
just didn't understand the inner
exchange I was having with Gary on
YouTube there's a marvelous marvelous
Series where Gary just talks in a very
personal easy relaxed way about you know
his whole